everybody give it up for Marvel games VP
and creative director Bill Roseman yeah
and Insomniac Games senior creative
director Brian intahar
oh hello yes yes yes yeah Ryan Josh yes
we're here we made it how you doing
buddy y'all
you have had quite the weekend well it's
been us first of all it's been yes it
has been an awesome weekend because of
all these True Believers yes so thank
you we appreciate it if you're at the
who was at the panel yesterday whoo yeah
was it cool cool stuff yeah yes so yeah
we had the panel yesterday uh seen all
the fans seen cosplayers seeing the
passion the love it's been great well
just what 2018 we were all up here again
on the marble Booth San Diego Comic-Con
it's crazy how it's like I mean we went
from signing these little posters to
like these gigantic Mondo posters that's
kind of like
kind of the evolution of Spider-Man 1
the Spider-Man 2. it's kind of
everything's gotten bigger and grander
so we're pretty excited to be here a
little bit of an upgrade well let's talk
about Marvel Spider-Man 2 bro yeah tell
us where Peter and miles are in this
game yeah so the game picks up roughly
nine to ten months after the events of
Miles Morales
um Peter is starting a new teaching
career miles is applying for college and
MJ is still at the Beagle but a new boss
under Jay Jonah Jameson who's returned
to the Beagle yeah
thing like life decisions yeah and you
know how it is as as as as you grow when
you get older you you have to make a
series of choices and I think the
characters now the the as the time has
passed they're really getting to a point
where it's like what am I gonna do with
my life yeah who am I going to be with
what do I want to do uh and so you throw
in things like Craven
on that and a certain symbiote that you
talk about correct what's I mean listen
yeah right now what can you tell us
about it
well I know what I can't say what I
can't say a lot can't say a lot what I
can say is
part of the reason one of the many
things I love about uh the insom team
and the PlayStation team is the love and
respect that they have for the Marvel
characters
I mean when we first got together we
just sat and talked about the Spider-Man
toys we had the comics we read how we're
lifelong fans how we all of us come from
you know the gaming and a Marvel
background and so be able to bring those
worlds together with the character that
we love so much so from that comes the
the the goal is it's not about
how many copies the game sells we hope
it sells a lot Awards it might win it's
all about we want people to say
that was made by fans for fans
that was a love letter to Spider-Man
all his creators and all the stories
that have come before uh but they also
did something new uh and we want people
to say that's why I love Spider-Man and
now the rest of the world can see why I
love games why I love Spider-Man yeah
and I think I think you know we talked
about the Symbiote right oh symbiote I
mean you did a really good job dodging
the question okay thank you thank you
again I think you know we you know about
five years ago I was asked when the
first question they got asked about
after the game came out was why is the
black suit in the game
even before the game came out we sat
around looking at all the different
suits we're gonna have in the game yeah
and we talked about if we were gonna
have the black suit in the game
we had to dedicate a game about that
suit and about the Symbiote right and I
think for us we understand how popular
it is why everybody loves it all the
elements whether it's the Symbiote the
bond with Peter how that impacts him and
his personality which you've seen in
some of the gameplay footage
um the eventual birth of venom
we realized that was going to take a
whole game to explore we want to make
sure we had uh the platform to do it and
after Miles Morales it just felt like
the next step for our journey with these
characters well just goes to show what
you said at Hall h a game made by fans
right so you know the the scope of Venom
yeah because if if they didn't they were
like oh let's just do what's that suit
that's cool yeah but they they of course
they knew there are some suits um that
you know some suits that we did alt
suits of that we couldn't really tell a
story because you know it comes from an
alternate like Spider-Man 2099 or
whatnot and we couldn't tell that story
but that one yeah they knew like hey
there is it's not just a suit there's a
story there's a history and also we know
how much people love Venom yeah and we
really wanted to deliver a Venom and a
Venom story that that people would want
and be happy with well let's transition
over to Miles Morales right yeah now
tell us new powers Brian tell us a
little bit about miles a new power yeah
so obviously you know in the first game
it was him showing he could be a hero
even before he had powers he saw what he
did to help Peter and MJ out um when the
Sinister Six came to be and in Miles
Morales it was about him you know
figuring out what kind of Spiderman he
wanted to be
um and then we saw you know it was by
electricity you know he's able to the
camo but what you're gonna see what we
call an evolved Venom and evolved by
electricity where it's a much more
volatile and uh it absolutely it's a
different color and there's like
everything we talk about Bill and I talk
about is that everything is revolved
around a story and errors we don't do it
for the sake of doing it so how those
Powers come to be how they play a role
The Return of Mr negative in miles's
life it's all kind of
intertwined so y'all released a Gameplay
trailer about a month-ish ago right
knowing that you can switch between
Peter Parker and Miles Morales yeah it's
true what was the inspiration behind
that what's going to be like when
players get to play as that well I think
you know this is this game is going to
be on the PS5 the PlayStation 5 and we
knew that that the console is going to
give us capabilities we couldn't do
before so being able to actually Place
both Peter and Miles not only just
during the main story but as you're
explore New York City you know miles
could be in in Harlem Pete could be
across the river in Queens with one
button press you can you can switch so
like you'll be able to switch on the Fly
explore the world how you want to you
know it's called Spider-Man 2 for a
reason because
there's two of them on the box right we
want to make sure that it's a story
about two amazing characters that we've
fallen in love with over the last decade
I love that now we get to switch between
these two amazing characters in Marvel's
New York new locations right tell us
about these new locations that's part of
what is also so cool about uh insom and
PlayStation and then Marvel itself
coming together
deciding what are we good what are we
going to do in the next game and it
could have just been more
it could have just been well here's you
love the first Spider-Man game here's
another one it's just more instead it's
like okay but what else can we add so in
addition to the new powers both for for
miles and Peter yep in addition to uh
new characters uh uh new alt suits uh is
the locations and and it's like okay we
have Manhattan built yep what else is
important to a Spider-Man story and so
then you start talking about well
Brooklyn and Queens because they have
connections to the characters so that's
why I love it's it's it's not let's not
just do more let's add how much can we
add that are going to throw fans and and
because we've built areas of the world
across the river we have to find a way
to get through there so we added the web
Wing so be able to Glide across the
river slingshire way across the river
um combine web wings and your your your
uh traditional swinging capabilities it
just and be able to move at speeds way
faster because the wind tunnels yeah
which almost can really go really yeah
it's almost like a highway for you so
you can swing jump in the wings hit
those wind tunnels uh then go back into
web swinging it's just I love it and the
first thing whenever outside of the
story the first thing they ever talk
about is like how can we make
swinging better like how can we make
traversal in the open world better
because it's such a core what and that's
what it can be we actually did think
about the web Wings on the first game
we're like let's just get swinging down
first and then we'll talk about the web
Wings later and then obviously that's it
was a big it was it was like on day one
and a half it's like we're gonna do the
web Wing so yeah yes I love it okay Bill
Bryan thank you so much let's give it up
for them one more time hey
October 20th yes Spider-Man 2 swings
into your hands we hope you enjoy it and
play it thank you thank you thank you
for your support we're trying to do
right by you and we appreciate you I
love it well let's get ready for some
giveaways as well y'all yes now our
awesome Partners at PlayStation have
provided 20 vouchers to the PlayStation
store that's right that's that's wild
okay chance to win those y'all we got
two chances you can either ask Brian or
Bill a question that's right you have a
chance to ask them a question or you can
answer a trivia question if you like we
got what if I answer a trivia question
I'll give you a high five okay
so come on down we will get you a line
right here to ask a question we'll do
some trivia as well but
so you don't have to get in line for
trivia just go ahead and put your hand
up should we do a trivia question we got
them right here for you let's do it
let's do it oh oh where's yeah yeah
there you go we got a hand we got a hand
all right yes uh right here uh right
yeah perfect so okay here we go this
these are trivia questions about the
Spider-Man games do you got it you ready
all right okay
aha
in Marvel's Spider-Man
the first game did you play it okay
what boss
does Spider-Man battle in the first
mission
yes very good way to go all right I
think we got let's let's change now to
our first question all right hey guys
how's
it going hey Brian Josh Evan good to see
you good to see you guys too the haulage
panel was incredible yesterday totally
focused on Venom and the black suit and
the Symbiote and it was phenomenal so my
question for you guys is seeing how big
of a roll Venom is going to play in the
game what does the character of Venom
mean to each of you
good question
uh would I
two things
uh well there's many but I'll only focus
on two
one thing we talked about what makes
Venom so scary is that he doesn't want
to rob banks
you know he doesn't want to uh uh uh
take over
the world Venom wants to kill Spider-Man
like that's his
uh so there's a there's an element of
fear
um and the second thing that I think is
very interesting is the idea of the
symbiote suit as an addiction
there are many different uh addictions
in the world and what can happen is uh
Sometimes some people feel like this is
my best self this is great and your
friends are like no you need to stop
doing this it's harmful to you and so
that's a very interesting Dynamic to see
play out amongst the characters and so
when we first sit down to talk about the
game in the story in addition to
gameplay we're always like what is the
story not the plot
what are some of the themes that we're
talking about
so there are talking about things
Darkness Darkness within
addiction uh friends being torn apart uh
or coming together as we say be greater
together so I think all those kind of
high concepts are really kind of
fascinating about
the Symbiote and Venom
yeah I think for me uh it comes down to
you know when people think of Venom
um for me it's venom is the equation of
the a host plus the Symbiote equals
Venom and not only are they bonded
physically but there's something else
emotionally that bonds them together so
I think
um when you play Marvel Spider-Man
you'll understand you know how that
comes to be based on the story we're
telling I love it well let's go back
into trivia now we're gonna make it
easier since I had a lot of pressure on
the audience let's ask a trivia question
first put your hands in the air if you
know it but we haven't even asked it yet
uh don't shout out the answer please we
have a chance for people to you know to
answer so uh Brian you want to do a
trivia question sure what items do you
have to collect to unlock the homemade
suit in Marvel Spider-Man all right we
gotta we got yeah we got Spider-Man
right here
correct correct yes all right Bill
another one okay
at the start of Marvel's Spider-Man
Miles Morales
during the mission to La Noche Bueno
Buena what comic book is on Miles
bedside table
and I have a hint if you need a hint the
hint it's Spider-Man's first appearance
oh I saw hat
five which number
there's there's a there's a there's a
and then there's a
yeah I love it all right Brian let's do
another one we got a lot of giveaway all
right what is Mary Jane's job in Marvel
Spider-Man I saw right in the back
but
for who for who
there we go
in Marvel Spider-Man who voices both
Peter Parker and Spider-Man
there we go
uh I have another one okay what type of
business does miles have to go to in
order to unlock spider cat and the suit
in Marvel Spider-Man Miles Morales what
type of business
Bodega nice
I'm out I'm out
you know them all thank you all right
well y'all let's give it up for Bill and
Brian again thank you thank you all for
being here y'all are incredible
absolutely thank you for hanging out
with us don't forget you can pre-order
right now Marvel Spider-Man 2 when it
comes out on October 20th yeah yo I
cannot wait for this game you have put
so much love and hard into this I can't
wait to flip around Marvel's New York
check out us at the Marvel booth for
more y'all thank you